Well,
why does that all the people are
automatically,
which is not true,
only about 5% of older people,
for example,
or a nursing obs with any kind of a
dementia or Alzheimer's disease.
The idea that they're unproductive and
can't be successful.
The workforce who may know their numbers
of them that are,
and they're very dependable and
hardworking people in the workforce,
the idea,
they're all sexless,
which is also not true.
They have desire,
capability and satisfaction unless have
a disease of some sort.
And even those who are now increasingly
treatable,
they're still capable of learning.
And a,
you know,
even,
right now they're already 74,007 areas.
That means people over 100 years of age
and they have remained independent and
capable of through their 90 50 year.
So,
uh,
there was no way to assume that people
are not able to learn just because
they're getting older.
Well,
it's built into the central nervous
system and it's simply hasn't played out
as yet.
I suppose he had the 200 year old
person.
Maybe they would have trouble,
but we don't know that yet.
Well,
I think one of the great ways to do it
is to learn something totally different,
like a new language,
a musical instrument,
because had rarely challenged as the
brain and learning more of the same,
like continue to do crossword puzzles
might be okay,
but it's not as desirable or as
powerful.
A stimulant to the central nervous
system is a brand new challenge,
like a new language or a musical
instrument.
Well,
the capacity for learning new things,
vocabulary,
building a judge Matt actually grows
with age of speed changes.
That is,
you're not as quick and responding to a
stimulus.
Oh.